各位這個AI做簡報的新功能太強了吧
你看這份簡報我從頭到尾花不到10分鐘就做好了
而且我全部都是在Gemini跟Google系統里面完成的 而且免費
嗨各位又是我AJ
Gemini終於推出了AI做簡報的功能
今天這集我們除了帶各位學會如何用Gemini做簡報之外
我們後面的重頭戲會分享如何透過Gemini還有Google Workspace的6大步驟
超高效的完成品質超好的簡報
而且資訊完全自動化 在開始之前呢
拿到YouTube官方AI證書的機會來了
我們這次跟Youtuber learning聯手推出了兩門超實用的AI課程
第一門是少年們的AI簡報影音大作戰 如果你家里面有國小國中生
這堂課會一步一步教他們用Gemini做出自我介紹
簡報 講稿 最後還能自己產出一支AI影片
第二門AI神隊友Gemini實戰互動課程 不管你是高中生
大學生 上班族 或者你只是一個開始想要用AI的人
這5堂課會帶你從基礎一路學到進階
兩堂課都上完之後就可以到連接里面的台灣數位文化協會的認證網站投稿
測驗 通過之後你就拿到全台唯一Youtuber learning認可的AI證書
真的不要等了
趕快一起來拿證吧
我們來到這個Google首頁那很簡單的來到Gemini
然後Gemini的這個首頁
那你要制作一份這個Gemini簡報現在有多簡單
你就直接打開工具然後打開Canvas
模型都可以
我建議是選Pro我建議是選Pro
好比如說就跟他說制作簡報如何舉辦一個超好玩的生日派對
然後就按送出
然後你大概只要等個一分鐘左右的時間
然後他就會轉轉簡報就做完了
就這麽簡單 好了
那我們來開啟看一下舉辦好玩的生日派對
就自動幫你把這些圖都準備好了簡報做好了
然後旁邊這邊 還有個按鈕叫匯出成簡報
你只要輕松的點一下
他就會幫你把那個簡報的這個預覽畫面
直接制作成一個Google slide的Google簡報
他就可以直接開啟
然後就可以把在Google slide里面的的這個簡報
你就可以去直接去做一些後續的調整跟修正
那就我們自己的測試
一次生成的簡報一個頁面大概會落在10-15頁之間
預設啦 那但如果你想要特別再多做一些的話
如果你餵進去的資料能夠多一點的話 那你的簡報大概可以做到20出頭頁
接著我們要來分享6步驟讓你可以去把這個簡報做得更加的專業
那我們就來重新開一個這個Gemini這個對話出來
那這一次我們要直接開啟這個叫做deepresearch的功能
現在deep research最近有更新的一些界面
所以他現在資訊來源除了可以做Google搜尋之外
其實他還可以從你的Gmail
你的雲端硬碟或者是你的這個Google chat
這幾個你都可以把它勾起來 我們這邊準備了
我們頻道的一些這個相關的這些後台的數據
你可以跟他說 我是這個泛科學院的YouTube制作人
請幫我研究我的資料
幫我分析我的頻道經營方針
然後接下來我們就按提交
那各位可以觀察到他會開始去做這個你的gmail也好
Google雲端硬碟也好各種各式各樣的這些資料
然後去做這樣的一個尋找
找完之後
他會根據你的指令自動的去判斷哪些資料是值得拿來做參考的資料
那這個部分就是我覺得Gemini還蠻聰明的一個地方
所以他挑選了我們剛剛給他的這些CSV檔案
還有一些這個頻道健檢季報之類的這些資料
好
那經過了一段時間之後 我們獲得了像這樣子的一個大家七頁左右的報告
我們就是很快速的哦把他做這個匯出到Google文件
然後我們再拿這一份報告回到我們的Gemini里面
好那這一次我們一樣啟用這個canvas
然後我們的來源檔案可以直接加入雲端印碟的檔案
然後去找到我們剛剛匯出的那一個Google雲端印碟的文件
提示想要怎麽下
請你針對我的內容制作適當長度的簡報
我要跟長官報告頻道經營的策略 然後一核心任務跟角色 視覺風格準則
然後 3 資訊架構準則然後就按送出
那你一定會好奇這東西到底怎麽做出來
如果你要做這樣的一個這個簡報生成提示詞
我們跟你分享一個小技巧 首先你要去給他一份
比如說你們公司過往的一些這個簡報的資料
那把這簡報放進去
然後你就可以跟AI講說
請作為簡報準則顧問 把這個簡報的細節寫出來
裡面的內容不是重點
重點是排版設計
文字圖表等等
所以我們這樣送出
我們就反手叫Gemini
作為一個簡報制作的這個結構的專家
幫你去分析你既有的這個簡報的這些制作設計的一些規則跟原理
所以我們用了這樣的一個這個技巧
那我們就很可以去生成一個非常覆雜的簡報的提示詞
所以
經過一段時間我們就看到像這樣子的 有12頁的簡報
然後還會附上一些經營方針
報告日期 還有一些小標
然後那個每個段落 你看數據都有出來
然後圖表也有出來
然後這些核心的這個主題
等等的這些相關的圖表
還有一些重點的這個績效矩陣 點閱率啦
相關這些數據 還有這個圖表 我們有檢查過這個圖表是對的
他一樣可以輕松的幫你匯出成簡報
所以你可以觀察到我們剛剛用很簡單的指令去下出
然後去讓他跑出一個簡報跟我們今天用一個覆雜的指令
而且我們用我們過往的這些制作過的簡報作為一個範例
請他去分析這個簡報之後給出的這個製作簡報提示語
最終做出來的簡報就會是一個相對來說完整度非常非常好的 那另外呢
如果你對他這個生成了簡報不滿意或者你需要加一點東西
那你可以
直接在這個地方用提示詞輸入的方式
來去要求他去做簡報內容這些修正跟更新
不過這時候在修正的時候我建議各位就直接選回去用flash
因為這個Pro是真的會跑比較慢的而已所以制作的第一份哦
你可以用Pro去做
可是後續如果你需要做一點小修小改小修小改那你用flash模型就可以了
看了這些簡報之後呢
你可能覺得說該講東西都有講
但是漏掉了一些東西
比如說那我想把這個資料放進去然後另外再做簡報那怎麽辦呢
你就先把這些你想要放進去的重點 把它選起來之後按個右鍵按複製
那你今天回到這個頁面里面
那你就很簡單的開一個新的空白頁貼上來到這邊
那你可以選擇右上角這邊
這個Gemini的這個icon提示詞很簡單
就是create a slide
about this page就這樣送出
通過這樣的方式也不用額外的扣點什麽的都不用啊
但是唯一一個重點就是你要下英文的提示詞
好我們試過中文的但是效果不太好 那這邊生成這個slide
你就可以很簡單的然後去做一些簡單的這個排版的調整
那到了這邊之後
他會生成這樣這張圖片 那當然這個圖片是怎麽做出來的
Naono banana 這邊有一個小小的技巧啦
如果你今天在這個里面你要去做這個圖片的更新
啟用Nano banana這個功能的話 你需要把你的這個操作界面暫時的
切過去英文 右上角這邊點選你的賬號
然後這邊會有一個管理你的Google賬戶
往下卷找到這個語音
在語言里面 要去新增一個語言
English United state
那新增完畢之後呢
把這個語言按一下這個向上的箭頭把它頂上去上面
現在這邊就變成英文的了
所以回到剛剛這個簡報
我們重新整理一下
在這個狀態之下你一樣要點選這個圖片
現在你這邊就會多一個叫做Edit image
那點這邊啊你就可以來去Edit這個image 比如說你就可以跟大家講說
change the
layout to blue就按create
好所以你看剛剛原本是紅色的 現在就變成藍色了
那就按replace
他就把你換過去了 如果簡報做出來但是這個簡報非常非常的正式
你會害怕這個不知道該怎麽講
那怎麽辦 那很簡單
你就直接
可以把這份簡報直接把它下載下來變成一個比如說PDF的這個檔案
你可以回到Gemini的網頁版
然後把剛剛的那個簡報或者其他的簡報把它丟上來
你可以跟他講說我要跟我的長官報告這個頻道的經營的策略
請參考我給你的資料
幫我設計GoogleSlide里面每一頁可以講的內容跟重點提醒
所以你就可以很清楚的看到我第一頁要講什麽東西
第二頁講什麽東西 他會有一些講稿
然後會有一些重點提示 好 那最後
你要做的事情就是這個部分要手動一下做
就是把這個東西覆制下來
然後回到我們的這個檢報里面
那在簡報里面的下面這邊會有一些這個簡報的談餐的這個講稿
你就可以把它放到這個下面來
這樣子你就完成了一個完整的簡報
包含要上台準備的這個整個的工作流程
好以上就是我們今天這集的一篇內容
如果你喜歡的話麻煩幫我們按讚訂閱加分享
那我們就下這一篇再見嘍拜拜